once there was a Miller who was poor but
who had a beautiful daughter now it
happened that he had to go and speak to
the king and ruled to make himself
appear important he said to him I have a
daughter who can spin straw into gold
the king said to the Miller that is an
art which pleases me well if your
daughter is as clever as you say bring
her tomorrow to my palace and I will try
what she can do and when the girl was
brought to him he took her into a room
which was quite full of straw
he gave her a spinning wheel and a reel
and said now set to work and if by
tomorrow morning early you have not spun
this straw into gold during the night
then you must die thereupon he himself
locked the room and left her inside
alone so there sat the poor miller's
daughter and for the life of her she
could not tell what to do she had no
idea how short could be spun into gold
and she grew more and more miserable by
the hour until she began to weep
uncontrollably but all at once the door
opened and in came a little man and good
evening mistress semilla why are you
crying so alas onse of the girl I have
to spin straw into gold and I don't know
how it can be done what will you give me
if I do it for you my necklace said the
girl the little man took the necklace
and seated himself in front of the wheel
and whirr whirr whirr three turns round
and the reel was full then he put
another and three more turns and that
will was also full and so it went on
until the morning when all the shore had
been spun and all of the reels were full
of gold by daybreak the king was already
there and when he saw the gold he was
astonished and delighted but his heart
became only more greedy he had the
miller's daughter taken into another
room full of straw which was much larger
and he commanded her to spin that also
in one night if she valued her life the
girl knew not how to help herself I was
crying when the door opened once again
and the little man appeared what will
you give me if I spin this straw into
gold for you the ring on my finger
answered the girl the little man took
the ring and again began to turn the
wheel and by morning he had spun all of
the straw into glittering gold the King
rejoiced beyond measure at the sight but
he had not enough gold and he had the
miller's daughter taken into an even
larger room full of straw you must spin
this - over the course of the night but
if you succeed then you shall be my wife
and he thought even if she is a miller's
daughter I could not find a richer wife
in the whole world when the girl was
alone the manikin came again for the
third time what will you give me if I
spin the straw for you this time I have
nothing left to give answered the girl
then promise me if you become queen your
first child shall be mine who knows
whether that will ever happen for the
miller's daughter and not knowing how
else to help herself she promised the
manikin what he wanted and for that he
wants more span the straw into gold when
the king came in the morning and found
all he had wished he took her in
marriage and the pretty miller's
daughter became a queen a year after she
had a beautiful child and she never gave
another thought to the manikin but
suddenly he came in her room now give me
what you promised the Queen was
horror-struck and offered the manikin
all of the riches in the kingdom if he
would leave her child know something
that its living is dearer to me than all
of the treasures in the wild the Queen
began to weep and cry so that the
manikin pitied her I will give you three
days time if by that time you find out
my name then you shall keep your child
so the Queen thought the whole night of
all of the names should ever heard and
she sent a messenger over the country to
enquire far and wide for any names that
might be when the manikin came in next
day she began with Caspar Melchior
Balthazar and said all of the names that
she knew one or the other but to
everyone the little man said the same
that is not my name on the second day
she had inquiries made in the
neighbourhood I said the names of people
that lived there and she repeated to the
manikin the most uncommon and curious
perhaps your name is short ribs or
Sheepshanks or even lace leg but he was
answered the same that is not my name
and the third day the messenger came
back once again I have not been able to
find a single new name but as I came to
a high mountain at the end of the forest
were the Fox and the hare bid each other
good night there I saw a little house
and before that house was a fire
and round about the fire was quite a
ridiculous man who was jumping he hopped
on one leg and shouted today I bake
tomorrow I brew the next I'll have the
young Queens child ha glad I am that no
one knew Rumpelstiltskin I am styled you
may think how glad the Queen was when
she heard the name now mistress Queen
what is my name is your name Conrad no
is your name Harry no it is not then
perhaps your name is Rumpelstiltskin the
devil eyes told you that the devil has
told you and in his anger he punished
his right foot so deep into the earth
that his whole leg went in and then in
rage he pulled at his left leg so hard
with both of his hands that he tore
himself in two
[Music]
you